so we are going to talk about what the
opposite of infinity what is the
opposite of infinity if it's not a minus
infinity then it is something that is
the smallest thing ever what is the
smallest thing you could have and not
quite zero the closest thing to zero
it's called an infinitesimal is it even
a thing
um because there should be something
about that that makes you feel a bit
uncomfortable it's been
an idea that's been controversial for a
long time i mean thousands of years some
people like it some people hate it so
what would an infinitesimal be the
smallest number possible uh close to
zero as possible so it would be
something that's bigger than zero
but it's smaller than all other numbers
let's say r for
number real number okay so smaller than
everything else that is
slightly uncomfortable because of this
if you had two numbers if you had a less
than b
there is always a number that i can fit
in between let's call it c there's
always something i can fit in between
and i can prove that because
c could be uh
a plus b divided by two and that's
proven there's always something you can
slip in
between two numbers no matter how close
you think they are you can always slip
in something else
so the idea of having the next number to
zero makes intuitive sense
um
but mathematically
it's it's alarm bells ring so this has
always been a problem um but people use
them to solve problems like this so
let's say i have a circle and i want to
know the area
so this is one way you could do it
i could take my circle and i could split
it up into triangles
these are meant to be very
small
thin
triangles these are wedges at the moment
but that's the problem we're going to
pretend they are triangles now they are
wedges if i pretend it's a triangle that
means it has a straight
base but the thinner it is
then the closer it would be to a
triangle so you kind of say okay well
let's pretend they're really really slim
right like the base is an infinitesimal
really slim as slim as possible and then
what you do is you take this circle of
triangles
and you kind of unwrap it like a hand
fan you know when you take a hand fan
you get like that that's what i'll do
with this circle that's my first
triangle down here right
so that's my center i'll take my first
triangle
right so there it is down here at the
bottom
i take the second triangle
still connected to the center i've kind
of stretched it though
so it looks like that and i take the
next triangle it's a bit stretched again
it looks like that i take the next
triangle
right so i take all my triangles i
stretch them out
they're all connected to the center
though like they were before
right so they get really stretched out
really thin so they turn to this right
it's actually turned into a triangle
you can see that can you see that
triangle i've done
my drawing is bad you see that's a
triangle now each of these
triangles here they've slim triangles
have the same area as they did to begin
with they've been stretched the
perimeter is different but they have the
same area because what is the area of a
triangle
it's a half the base times the height
although they've been stretched they've
got the same height
up to here they've got the same base and
so the area is the same
but the big triangle i've made
it has height altogether
the radius of the circle ah
and the length of its base
is the circumference of the circle
so what is the area of this triangle
it is a half
at the base is the circumference the
height is the radius that's the area of
the triangle the circumference 2 pi r
right so it's a half times
2 pi
r for the circumference times r and you
get pi r squared and that is the area of
the circle you get the right formula so
for the area of the circle and so you
did it by splitting it up in thin bits
and kind of adding them together with
this clever idea
the guy who came up with that idea is
kepler do you know kepler the guy who
worked out the elliptical orbits of the
planets so he was interested in working
out the areas of an ellipse there is
something that should make you feel
uncomfortable though because there's
there's always that little small error
isn't there i mean they were saying
these triangles were approximating the
words there's always this this is what
the problem people have have with
infinitesimals it's always
not quite yeah what happened to all
those curve bits so what they did what
the mathematicians were doing and when
they were using is they were ignoring
them so these mathematicians who were
using infinitesimals were saying well
it's really close to zero we'll ignore
it and then there are other
mathematicians saying well hang on you
can't just think no it might be close
but it's not the same
and they can't be ignored and this is
the problem people have but yet
it seems to have worked
i'll show you a different idea that they
used to do right just throwing my money
around because i'm so rich i can throw
my pennies around
yeah so the idea is i've got my stacks
of pennies here and they're meant to be
two cylinders right
but if i took this one and started to
mess it up a bit so it wasn't a cylinder
to do something like that
okay so that's not a cylinder anymore
but the idea is what the mathematicians
said was well if you took it if you
compared them slice by slice
then each slice has the same
cross-sectional area it's like a the
area of a penny here so you can say that
this
has the same volume as a cylinder it's
not a cylinder but because you can
compare it slice by slice instant by
instant
they have the same
volume
but those those slices don't have depth
they don't have volume themselves so you
are comparing cross-sectional area to
cross-sectional area so it's kind of
like adding up all these cross-sectional
areas
but they don't have depth so you're
adding up all these
zero
these things with zero depth so how can
you add them all up and get
a volume but that's a that's something
they would do you can compare two shapes
like that and if they if each instant
has the same
area we can say they have the same
volume so it was this idea going around
as well and then it was infinite test
balls were really important when newton
and leibniz started to use them in when
they
discovered or invented calculus
which is a massive subject in maths
really important so in the 17th century
they discovered
calculus
and this was trying to work out the area
under a curve
right
so let's try and work out the area under
a curve so what you could do is you
could take this curve you want to find
the area
underneath it here
so you could split this up
into thin
strips
and you were saying that each of these
strips were like a rectangle if you had
if you turn that into a rectangle you do
get a little bit of error
but the thinner the rectangles
the smaller the error so you could add
up all these rectangles and find out
find areas under curves which is
something mathematicians do and so what
newton and leibniz were doing i might
use a different color so there's chopped
it up and let's say yeah i have like a
little bit more here just make it a
different color
so
the base of this rectangle is
something small infinitesimal perhaps
and i'll call that oh i'll call that
delta that's actually a traditional
notation so let's do that
and what they were saying is if this
curve you call these curves things like
f of x so what i'm saying is if this
here is x then this is going to be x
plus delta x plus a little bit
and the width of the base is delta if
you work out this area
all the way up to x plus delta let's
take the area of all the way up to
x plus delta and i subtract
all this green bit here that's less than
x
so subtract the
area that is here below x that is equal
to the area of this strip
so i've subtracted all the other strips
and what is the area of that strip
it is f x that's the height of the
rectangle
multiplied by
this little base
or to put it another way
you can say the function
is
x delta minus the area less than x
divided by delta
so what they noticed is that the
function was rate of change of area uh
it might sound a bit
uh
abstract but this is the big discovery
that newton and leibniz made that was
actually hugely important because it
means that you could work out area by
working out rate of change and rate of
change was something that they could do
and newton and leibniz were both working
on this at the same time and they both
knew of each other's works kind of
but leibniz published first
and then newton published three years
later his prince prince pia mathematica
and there was this big debate about who
who came up with it first
uh and it got really nasty newton was
really you know he really wanted to
protect his discovery
um and leibniz was almost
you know couldn't be bothered to argue
anymore
and uh and in the end they set up this
committee to work out who discovered
calculus first and it was all newton's
friends
and newton himself wrote the report
and you know what they discovered that
newton came up with it first
uh and so and leibniz then died uh with
his discovery
i guess taken away from him or yeah the
you know the honor of the discovery
taken away from him and historians have
looked at their notes and they've
decided that they came up with it
completely independent of each other
so now they both get credit but this
uses infinitesimals
it's the same problem and newton you
knew this as well there's always this
little bit of error
it doesn't doesn't quite work and in the
end
about 200 years later they started to
tidy this up and they got rid
of the infinitesimals they realized you
don't need to use the infinitesimals
they started they had this new idea
called limits
where these could get thinner and
thinner and thinner and they would
approach zero and this is called a limit
and this was mathematically rigorous and
consistent and it meant that you didn't
have to use
infinitesimals to work out these areas
and they could be thrown out of the
theory and
not needed anymore and
there are no
infinitesimals in the real numbers
they were gone
and then they made a comeback it's you
can't keep a good idea down it made
another comeback in the 20th century it
took to the 20th century for it to make
another big comeback the 1960s
a guy worked out a system where you
could include the infinitesimals
you can have a mathematically rigorous
and consistent system you can solve
problems using this system
the guy was a guy called abraham
robinson
it was in the 1960s he could only do
this in the 20th century because it
required
mathematics that had been done in the
20th century they took the real numbers
and then they added in
infinitesimals into what was already
there so
infinitesimals don't exist in the real
numbers but they they added them in so
they said an infinitesimal
is something that satisfies this right
it is something that is less than all
the other real numbers
and bigger than zero all right so they
added this this idea in so it is an
addition it's called the hyper reals so
you've got these infinitesimals let's
call them e so
this is an infinitesimal
and you also have an infinite in this in
this system so you have something that's
one over an infinite decimal is an
infinite and that's allowed that's
included
if you have two numbers that are
infinitely close together if you said x
and y are close together that means x
minus y
is an infinitesimal
so there is an idea of being
infinitesimally close in this system in
the real numbers zero is the only
infinitesimal um in the real numbers we
know we we would never do this would we
one divided by c zero is not infinity we
would never do that and that is still
true in the hyper reals everything
that's true in the reals is still true
in the hyper reals so that is not true
in the real numbers and it's not true
in the hyper reals either so something
like this um x plus y equals y plus x
that's true in the real numbers and it's
true in the hypervisors
if you have x squared is greater
than x
where x has to be bigger than one that's
true in the real numbers and it's true
in the hyper real numbers
we know that 2x is not equal to x
that's true in the real numbers
and it's true in the hyper-real numbers
which means
if you had an infinitesimal
an infinite decimal is not the same as
two times the infinitesimal it's not
same as three times or four times or
n times these are all different they're
all infinitesimals but they're all
different
so these yeah these things are not the
same so there's lots of infinitesimals
there's not just one infinitesimals
there are lots you know there's a nice
little quote it's this guy abraham
robinson wanted to get into the mind of
leibniz that was that's the quote that
i've read that he wants to get into his
thinking and the thinking of
infinitesimals and can we make this work
and can we use it
now this system
finally is consistent it is rigorous
it can be used properly
it can be used to solve problems it's
called non-standard analysis
people fans of this system
say it's more intuitive and they say it
can solve problems
with shorter proofs it has finally
made
another comeback
because what about now before we divided
by 2 if k was even
but in the real numbers all the non-zero
elements and k is certainly not zero all
the non-zero elements you can take the
reciprocals you can divide by them